Hello, hello, hello!
Welcome, welcome back!
I wonder if this is your first stream ever.
Howdy.
Oh my gosh.
First ever.
Hello, hi everybody.
Hi, hi.
Hi, hi, hi.
Can we get a nya?
Nya.
Can I get a hype?
Hype.
One second.
Okay, there we go.
Nya.
Wait, one second.
Also, the game feels a little loud.
Wait.
Where is it?
Oh, it's me.
I'm a loud one.
My headphones were turned up.
Sorry, I know you can't hear it right now.
Oh, I knew it.
I knew it.
Sorry, I had a setting that I turned off.
And I was like, wait a second.
I don't think I turned it back on.
First time here, what's with this talking cat?
I'm the cat of the sewers.
I'll make your, I'll grant you one wish.
What is your wish, young boy?
boy
can we see stummy can you say please where are your banners tummy time where are your banners did your did your parents teach you not to say anything the parents teach you to say hi dog Congratulations on that on the adorable new outfit.
Thank you.
This game's story is brutal But amazing.
I hope you like it Brutal
How Did someone spoil this had zombies in it?
Everyone's gonna be safe like in Detroit become human right?
Oh Oh the tax the tox plasmosis.
Yeah You can get that from cats.
Apparently, it, like, makes you love your cat.
I don't know if I said it right.
Tom, new cat in the taking, Tom, taking, talking.
Claims to be an edible in the title.
Yeah, it looks like a snack.
Would you do the honor of showing a little bit of stummy?
My goodness.
We just started.
We just started the stream!
Can we fool furriers?
Do it like Inuyasha style.
Money goes to tummy.
Okay.
Sorry, when I click out of the game, it stops it stops the the sound this is the only stummy i'll give today it's the only stummy i give today i won't put my glasses on otherwise it's too embarrassing it's so quiet i know can you see me i've got to eat your don't know okay oh
YouTube!
YouTube, I promise!
I promise I'm wearing...
I have pants on!
Tommy, Tommy, Tommy, Tommy, Tommy, Tommy, Tommy Tommy, Tommy, Tommy, Tommy Tommy, Tommy, Tommy, Tommy, Tommy, Tommy, Tommy, Tommy, Tommy, Tommy, Tommy, Tommy, Tommy, Tommy, Tommy, Tommy, Tommy, Tommy, Tommy, Tommy.
I wonder if I'll be blocking any text.
We'll adjust as we go along.
We shall adjust.
MGS boxes.
Get your MGS boxes.
Oh, wait.
I saw someone say that they re-put the MGS boxes for Peace Walker and for, but I already ordered them.
So, but I don't want to spend another lot of money I spend so much money on stinking metal gear acrylic standees you guys because they're releasing standees acrylic standees of every character every game and so I was like I really have no place for this I have nowhere to put these little guys but I I I can't resist Even the grunts,
I think there was, uh, I think MGS1 had the genome soldier.
The box for the acrylic standies of the MGS, of MGS1.
And so I was like, oh my gosh, I want to have like 15 pies acrylic standies, but I'll have just one.
I'll take just one, you know.
But, oh, I couldn't resist.
I was like, give me more plastic.
More plastic.
I want to collect all the plastic.
You guys know that audio?
That's just like, I don't want to, I don't want to, I don't actually remember what the actual audio is.
But it's like, I don't want to do this thing.
But the parasites, the parasites told me to do this thing.
I don't want to, it's like, I don't want to drink.
I can remember.
It's like, I don't want to eat that cake.
I don't want to eat it.
But the parasites, the parasites tell me to know.
Oh yeah, I don't want candy.
I don't want to eat that candy.
But the parasites, that's me.
I don't want acrylic stands.
Shelf fund.
From someone who frequently runs out of space for plastic.
I recently boxed up.
Here I'll let the music or the sound.
sound effects play again.
I recently boxed up a bunch of figures that I will be taking.
I sometimes box my figures up and take them with me to Japan and then sell them.
Like Mandarake.
And so I was just like, well, I need more space.
So I did that with some figures.
Can't say do the work, but really happy you're playing one of my favorite games of my birthday.
Zenova, happy birthday.
Good luck with work.
Good luck, good luck.
Oh, did someone...
Did someone write?
Thank you for the break!
Thank you, thank you!
Hey, kids.
Thank you so much for the gifted.
Ducky, thanks for the gifted.
Miguel, welcome back.
Thank you.
Or welcome?
Wait, I can't tell.
I can't remember what's the...
I don't remember what the...
I changed recently the membership little icons.
I can't remember what's what.
Call me a zombie the way I want to...
Don't say that.
I'm not finishing this message.
I'm not doing it.
Wrong, Parama.
Thank you so much for the fun, good to thank you.
Dwarago, thank you for the fun, good to...
Thank you, guys.
Thank you, thank you, thank you.
There's really nothing wrong with getting more Metal Gear merch.
Yeah.
I have too much stuff.
Ah!
Got a new motorbike on the day of your new outfit.
It's orange and black, so I'm thinking of naming it the Cyber Tiger.
Wait, that's so good!
That's so good!
Phil, thank you for the five-git-git-git-vibigoy, thank you for the five-git-git-tigoo!
Inside about the Slayer song.
Even though it was so scuffed.
Yeah.
But this is my first time ever playing the Walking Dead game.
I have seen other people play it, but I did not, like, watch, you know?
Like, I was like, oh, this evening, I want to try it myself.
So, I have held off.
So, this is all brand new, first-time experience.
I have no prior knowledge of anything.
Or comics?
No, I never read the comics.
I watched the show up to Negan, which I feel like was a lot of people.
I feel that was quite a bunch of people.
So, uh, also, uh, I have a cover coming out tomorrow with a Nimi Nightmare.
So, um, so, uh, I have a pinned, pinned link in the, in, in the, uh, comments?
Yeah, in the comments.
And, um, if you're watching the VOD, it might be out.
So you should go watch.
Listen.
Yes, yes, yes.
Is that what I'm wearing in the apocalypse?
Oh, yeah.
I don't know.
I kind of...
That's like a genre I really like is like the...
Kind of like a...
I...
Well, actually, so more than post-apocalyptic settings, I like watching the...
That time when all the chaos is happening, like the pre-apocalypse but like when everything like i like seeing patient zero you know what i mean i like seeing how it how everything starts to spiral yeah the collapse it's so freaky but i it's like it's like i can't look away it's so fascinating to me so have i ever played fallout i haven't but i do want to i do want to try it one day the beginning of the end yes yes yes I think it's I've mentioned this this movie slash TV series quite a few times before but the stand like Stephen King's the stand I think part one is all like the everything's going down and I can remember that part so well I watched it so often as a young wisp I was a wee,
I was a wee little wisp, and I was like, I was like that to my screen, like, watching everything happen.
But I don't remember anything in part two.
I don't remember.
I don't even know what happens.
I just...
I don't know what happens.
Did you watch It?
Like, Stephen King?
It?
The new one?
Yes.
Yeah, I think I actually recently watched it on the plane.
Artemis, thank you so much for the five kids!
Thank you!
Thank you, thank you.
Hope that you and everyone else here have a great day.
White Wolf, thank you, you too!
You too, you too, you too.
What about the prequel?
That.
It.
It?
What?
What would be like?
So you have it and then you have...
Oh yeah, that.
My brain wanted to say there.
But that's...
That's incorrect.
Then?
It's been a while since I so bought a scary day.
Kai is trying to pull me out of my coworker out of a vehicle?
Monster, are you okay?
I hope you're okay.
Recently started playing the MGS games.
I hope you like them.
I saw somebody in pre-chat say that they got to the part of MGS2 where they were talking about King Kong.
That's what I was talking about.
When I mentioned King Kong.
Yes.
It, too.
Penny wiser.
Penny.
No.
What if he's not penny?
What if he becomes nickel or dime?
Quarter.
Two penny, two wise.
then also known as tony hawk's existential nightmare i love how how people just can't recognize tony hawk they'll be like oh man you you you're pretty good at skating or they'll be like you look just like tony hawk
do a kickflip
Pennywise Dollar Dumb
That's me I'm a Dollar Dumb I'm a Wait I'm I wanna be I wanna be a Shiny quarter He's like if Pliskin picked up a skateboard Wait Ugh Dumb apparently Dolly Parton once went to Dolly Parton look-alike contests and lost miserably.
Wait, I literally was reading about that yesterday.
Like, actually, because I was watching a video of Adele doing the same thing, where she went to an Adele contest, and they were all singing, like, the same song, and then actual Adele went last, and she started singing, and one of the Adele look-alike girls was like,
like, Like, almost immediately, she was just kind of sitting there, like, listening.
And then she goes, But, and so that it kind of got me into a rabbit hole of, like, like, the Dolly Parton one, too, how she went, how she participated in the Dolly Parton lookalong.
Lookalong contests and lost.
It's kind of insane.
But with Adele, she apparently wore, like, prosthetics, like, a different nose and stuff, so people...
Wouldn't realize it's her.
Remember, anyone that you let die is a personal and moral failing!
Okay.
Not on my conscious.
I'm eager to watch Stephen King's The Long Walk movie.
I forgot to read it, but my wife did and she loved it.
Oh, wait, is there a new movie coming out?
It's them, us, him, and you.
Wait, yeah, wait, those are all horror thrillers, aren't they?
That's crazy.
That's so crazy.
Ninja Shadow, welcome to Babyship to Haku.
Did she wear a clown nose as a disguise?
She, she, she, she, she.
She.
I think that would be the best disguise.
guys um but yeah i guess we'll get started walking dead time i will do my best to keep people alive and also try to be your best with uh about spoilers since this is my first time playing okay
uh choose a display style more help from ui and feedback when you make important choices turn off UI hints and choice notification Glenn will remember you lie settings can be changed later a standard better since I've never played this before maybe standard okay episode one a new day I'm gonna keep everybody alive I promise.
But not pinky promise, because this game series adapts to the choices you make.
The story is tailored to how you play.
But I'm not going to pinky promise, because if you break your promise, you'll break your pinky.
The Walking Dead.
The narrator.
She didn't.
Episode 1.
A new day.
Are we going to be in handcuffs the whole game?
That would be...
Intense.
Don't look at me!
Well, sky's on the road, mister.
Well, I reckon you didn't do it then.
Uh-oh, are there no subtitles?
Uh, oh, use the mouse wheel to select a response.
You know what they say about reckoning.
Oh, does it really matter?
Yeah.
Let's be done.
Does it really matter?
Nah, not much.
Hold on.
I'm gonna have settings.
Audio?
So, uh, graphics?
Eh?
Gameplay?
Subtitles?
Why are they automatically off?
Is there anything else I should turn on?
Show controller, uh, I don't know.
Thank you guys.
Resume.
You know, I've driven a bunch of fellas down to this prison.
Lord knows how many.
Usually it's about now I get the, I didn't do it.
I didn't do it.
And what do you say?
Not for me.
Every time?
Yeah, I doubt all these guys are doing this every time.
Really?
I didn't do it, officer.
It wasn't me.
He's here, P3A6, 285.
Wow.
Are
you looking at me?
Is he getting a wink at me?
I followed your case a little bit.
You being a making boy, no?
A baking boy?
Oh, so you're from making them?
You're from making, Ben?
Yep, came up to Atlanta to be a city cop in the 70s.
Oh, that's right.
This takes place in Atlanta.
Like that senatorial mess you got yourself mixed up in.
With all due respect.
We're going to Phantom Thief.
A real shit.
it's atlanta it's not so odd that a cop car is gorgeous your folks drugstore right in downtown still there sure is sure is good like rake in artsfield any of that seems important to you all of it but that box never shuts up sit in this seat and pay too much attention and you'll drive yourself crazy i got an f you up at uga you teach long count on the six year you meet your wife in Athens you want to know how I see it sure this guy's nice sure how do you sure oh regardless could be you just married the wrong woman oh or she Oh,
screw you!
Or she married the wrong guy.
Oh.
It was such a fast...
Such a fast decision.
Grrr.
It's all going down, you guys.
Uh-oh.
Wait, where is he taking me?
I'm driving this man once.
He was the worst one.
stop going on about how he didn't do it.
He was an older fella.
Big soft eyes behind a pair of smart folk glasses.
And he's just wailing back there.
Says it wasn't him.
Why are you passing in the right lane, huh?
Right where you sit.
Why is everybody going so slow in the left lane?
It's making me annoyed.
Like a fussy baby on an airplane.
I'm not telling him he's got to stop.
That's government property and I'll be forced to zap him on the road.
You're making me anxious.
Haven't exhausted all his options.
He starts crying out for his mama.
Oh.
Mama, it's all a big mistake.
It wasn't me.
Were you driving goofy?
So did he do it?
They caught the fucker red-handed.
Stabbing his wife, cutting her up as the boys came through the door.
He sits in my car screaming bloody murder that it wasn't him.
I think he actually believed it himself.
Oh my gosh.
it goes to show people up and go mad when they believe their life is over I got another good one for you this one's a little bit less depressed they're more hilarious about who sleeps out this other time
holy years oh
my god yeah where are the airbags
Best distracted driving PSA.
I called it.
I knew it would happen.
I kept seeing this man.
Stop looking at the road.
I knew it.
Oh.
Shit.
Thanks.
Thirsty.
Oh.
Fuck.
Uh oh Uh oh Use the mouse to look around Find a look at shotgun We have a window Kick in the window With our leg What the hell did he have his gun out Why does he have a shotgun Also just let me know I know my hair kind of is is big.
If you need me to put on another hairstyle, I can so I'm not blocking as much of the subtitles.
Now I want her to play the wolf among us.
Thank you so much for the Akasupa bread.
Thank you.
Make it bigger.
It's all good.
Bald!
One more!
What?
Okay, let's not make so much...
Let's not make so much noise.
Now move towards the window using W.
Wait, what's it saying?
I need to drag myself out that window.
Oh, shimmy, shimmy.
Look at the door.
Use the mouse wheel to select an action.
Oh, okay.
I was wondering what the gameplay would be like in this.
Try fog.
Don't look at him.
Use W to move along the car.
Isn't this a serious game?
Oh my gosh, don't go up to that guy, please.
Or grab the gun, please.
Oh my gosh.
Shotgun shell.
So we did shoot.
Okay.
The officer's shotgun is over there.
Yeah, grab it.
Oh, grab it.
Why would he have needed that?
His facial expressions?
Well, he's just kind of like...
Look, I'll do it again.
Oh, wait.
Now he's picking it up.
I did that before, though.
Looks empty.
Yeah, let's take that.
It'll be easier to carry with these cups off.
Oh, gosh.
I was going to say, let's grab it before we go over to him, though.
Oh.
officer oh is this the keys on him or in the car damn oh my god officer officer officer god damn officer officer officer officer damn where's the keys in the car Okay, the way he's staring at me.
Go, officer.
Pick it up.
Take it, though.
I don't like all the crap.
King's out.
Looks empty.
It'll be easier to carry with these cuffs off.
Am I missing something?
I'm already lost.
Gotta get close.
Oh, I thought I was pretty close.
No?
Ah!
Oh no.
Oh, this is a grabby grab scene.
Oh my gosh.
Look at that!
That's the face of a man that is turned.
Officer?
Um...
Okay, I'm ready for the QTE.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
Good, good plan.
Good plan.
My man is smart.
Nice.
Oh my gosh.
I know.
Okay, it saves.
Ow!
Estabar, I'm going!
What in the hell?
Where the fuck are you?
Where's the shotgun?
I'm pressing...
I'm pressing S to get away.
There we go.
I was stuck on something, I think.
Grab the shotgun!
I have no qualms about it.
Oh, I thought I missed because he jerked his head back.
I'm definitely going to jail now.
Out of the frying pan, complete chapter one of episode one.
The skin's all rotten and he smells like shit.
what the hell is this oh my gosh that's a person mysterious figure go get someone there's been a shooting she just so calmly oh oh she isn't
oh my gosh why would you trip over him please I think it's time to go.
How have so many people turned already?
Sorry, it's lagging a little bit.
I don't know why.
Whoa, whoa, it's lagging a lot.
Is this normal?
Yeah, it's normal.
Oh, that's fine.
Oh, he's so strong.
Oh, my gosh.
Oh, I thought they were in the yard, too.
Is the game not me?
Thanks for the reassurance.
This used to be on iOS?
No way.
How did so many people turn so fast?
Oh my gosh.
Anybody?
Now, I don't think that's smart.
now I don't think it's wise to a yell when we know that they're attracted to sound fill one of those teacups with some bourbon if I could so true no ladder I'm not getting up there anyway this leg the way it is yeah well there is a ladder it's just two two steps stop stop doing that don't sit please mr I wonder if anybody's home Okay,
right Let's Let's um Do that Let's do that Let's let's lock ourselves in a house That would surely be Wait I wonder if anybody's home Alright And we go Anybody home Anybody home I need a little help.
I'm not bit, I promise.
Okay.
No help.
Good thing, good thing it's not...
Please stop, please stop!
You're scaring me, mister.
Maybe I should just check inside the house through the glass door before wandering out into the neighborhood.
I did!
Nobody picked up.
now imagine if it were you guys in the apocalypse in the zombie apocalypse some guy comes up to your door no help oh wait there we go
no kidding
I'd already be a zombie I think I would give up don't shoot okay luckily I am a ghost so I don't think i can turn into a zombie i'm like dead dead not living though hello i'm not an intruder or one of them oh no no no no no mr mr mr people may need more help than i do
oh unicorn it's not even she didn't even finish color in the grass oh oh Oh, Jesus.
Fruit.
A bowl of fruit.
Yeah, take one.
It's fake.
Oh.
Dang, people and their fake-ass fruit.
Bookshelf.
Furniture overturned.
Blood everywhere.
Jesus.
Though, I kind of get it.
Because, like, fake fruit will never attract flies.
Just saying.
God, that kid lived here.
Clementine.
Ugh, cable's out.
So fast already?
How long were we out?
But you can't eat it.
Yeah, but it looks nice.
Moshe, Moshe.
Three new messages.
Message
him.
Hey, Sandra.
This is Diana.
We're still in Savannah.
hotel so we had to get him back to the er and have it checked out anyway he's not feeling well enough to drive back tonight so we're staying an extra day thanks so much for looking after clementine and i promise we'll be back in time before your spring break savannah but that's so far from atlanta i thought it started at the cdc right isn't that the story i don't know if you try
please just leave the city and take clementine with you back to murietta i've got to get back to the safe message three left at 6 51 a.m clementine baby that's 9 1 1 oh we love you we love you
uh she looks old enough to know 9 1 1 i hope daddy oh hello hello i'm gonna get i'm gonna i'm gonna get a knife first
Oh, walkie-talkie.
Yeah.
Who is this?
I'm Clementine.
This is my house.
Hi, Clementine.
I'm Lee.
You're not my daddy.
Oh.
No, I'm not.
Your daddy's gone.
He got bit.
Patient zero.
Um, how old are you?
How old are you?
Yeah.
Eight?
She knows 911.
Yes.
I don't know where anybody is.
Wait, your parents went to Savannah?
I'm...
When you're eight years old and left you here?
Okay.
I'm 37.
Where are your parents?
They took a trip and left me with Sandra.
They're in Savannah, I think.
Where the boats are?
Are you safe?
Oh, yeah, where are you?
Where are you?
I'm outside in my tree house.
Oh.
They can't get in.
That's smart.
Okay.
See?
Can you see me?
I can see you through the window.
She's so cute.
Hi.
What's cute?
Oh, sorry.
I forgot to press it.
I was so focused on Wasta.
Are you dead too?
Yes, man.
Yes, I'm dead.
Q!
Wait, how do I do this?
Q?
Oh, I see!
I have to keep pressing at E?
Do I hold?
Q?
I press a lot?
E?
I hold?
Oh my god!
I'm slipping.
Uh...
Yeah!
Ouchie, ouchie, let's go.
Oh my gosh!
Is that Sandra?
Q I...
Oh, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q, Q.
Oh,
crap.
One more.
Whoa!
I learned how to do the controls.
Dang, that's gruesome.
hi was that Sandra just don't look did you kill it oh Clementine don't look uh something else did yes yes what do you mean it's okay I think she was a monster I think so too but we've been all by yourself Clementine will remember that yeah I want my parents to come home now I think that might be a little while you know oh look I don't know what happened but I'll look after you until then oh what should we do now um let's get out of here no not once the Sun goes let's let's look for help before it gets dark we need to find help before it gets dark yeah it's not safe at night yeah scream loud for help let's go stay close to me.
He's covered in blood.
Oh my gosh.
He needs to get, he should like search for like a something, like a, not a tourniquet, but something to like put on his leg, you know?
The Q and QTEs.
How did something get into the house?
That's my question.
Yeah, splint.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Something.
The house has perfectly good stuff, probably.
I'm moonwalking.
oh does that person look alive oh yeah they're they're alive okay oh man i ain't never getting home to mama at this rate this sucks it's hot dish night hot dish do you not care about what's going on
open gate what's the matter should i stay what I don't want to sleep in the tree house tonight but I don't know if I should leave what if my parents come home they won't let's go I won't leave you I won't leave you alone yeah yeah let's go somewhere safe that's close okay that's a good idea shout out happy birthday
hey man holy don't eat us we're not gonna hurt you yeah thought for a second you and the little one we're both gonna get oh my gosh look at the guy in the background oh what's going on do you know what the hell this is what's going on no idea so you've seen them then yeah we've seen them you could say that i'm sean sean green sean This is Clementine.
I'm Chet.
Chet.
We shouldn't be out in the open like this.
How about you help us clear the way and we'll take you and your daughter out of here and down to my family's farm.
It should be safer there.
Oh.
I'm not a dad.
I'm...
I'm just some guy.
Just some guy.
Some guy?
Sean noticed.
She's alone?
Let's get going.
Staying put for too long is a mistake.
Maybe that was the wrong thing to say.
Maybe that makes sense.
Maybe look a little suspicious.
Hey.
The monster's coming.
We gotta go.
Oh no!
Oh, what?
Okay.
If what?
Wait, what was this guy doing then?
You guys were both trying to push this out of the way, no?
Oh my gosh.
Even Clementine trying to help.
Poor sweet little baby.
Oh my gosh!
Go, go, go, go, please!
Oh, Chet!
For just some guy, it seems like you saved a bunch of lives today.
Oh!
Chet's a hero.
He jumped in the back.
He didn't have to do that.
He could have let us sit in the back, you know?
area seat.
We're on the farm.
I don't think this is Kansas no more.
Great.
There, by the way.
Thank you.
Of course I'm going to finish the game.
Hey, Sean.
I'm going to run on home.
My mama's going to be in a snip.
No sweat, man.
I'll catch you tomorrow night.
They're so casual about this.
They're so casual.
He's just like, yeah, I'm just going to walk home.
no biggie hello thank god you're okay i was worried it'd be bad here too been quiet as usual the past couple days well breckin down the way thinks his mayor's gone lame but that ain't nothing new i wouldn't have made it back without chat well i'm glad you took him with you then um you've brought a couple guests uh your boy's a lifesaver yeah let's play boys a lifesaver glad he could be a help to somebody so it's just you and your daughter then oh not his daughter he's well just some guy who found her alone honey do you know this man oh yes yes you do okay then okay well looks everybody's suspicious of me yeah it's not doing so good I can help you out.
Sean, head on in and check on your sister.
You take a seat up on the porch and I'll see what I have.
He's bliskin, he's just some guy.
Let's have a look.
I'm not infected.
Yeah, this is swollen to hell.
It hurt, uh, it could be worse.
Could be worse.
That's what it sounds like.
Seems like things got awful bad in the cities.
Yeah.
What did you say your name was?
It's Lee.
We'll play it nice.
Nice to meet you, Lee.
I'm Herschel Green.
Herschel Green.
We'll play it nice.
How'd this happen?
Uh, car accident.
Car accident.
We'll be honest.
That's so.
Where are you headed before the car accident?
Why are you so nosy?
Out of Atlanta.
I was getting out of Atlanta.
The news says stay.
Yeah, well that's a mistake.
Yeah, true.
one of those things you've been hearing about on the road who are you with the girl nobody nobody is that so yeah it is you said we that's all oh house is full up with mine we got another displaced family of three sleeping in the barn oops why are you so I didn't get your name darling Clem Nancy drew over here I know I'm looking after until we find her parents hey why are they so sus of me first thing tomorrow we got to reinforce the fence around the farm that doesn't seem necessary oh I don't know what you saw on TV or heard on the radio but there's some serious shit hitting the fan I don't think anyone knows how big it is yet your son is right your son's right you're gonna want to fortify this stuff like that doesn't happen here Sean dad I'm serious Lee come on tell him what you saw out there man oh uh dead people walking I got chased by a couple of dead people well do what you think you should we got plenty of chores as it is oh my god me and those folks in the barn can help out in
the morning we got to do it really you got to do it tonight he said okay well I'm all done here you're starting to feel better
It gets hot or the swelling doesn't go down.
You're probably dealing with an infection.
Uh-oh.
What do we do then?
We'll probably just have to shoot you.
Hot Clementine's face.
We'll clean it, redress it, and you'll be fine.
Okay, that'd be preferable.
There's blankets and such in the barn.
We'll be seeing you bright and early.
Come tomorrow, which way you think you're headed?
Towards making, I suppose.
Where are we?
on a farm in the middle of nowhere everybody's sleeping in the barn okay it smells like like my new you know I know what it smells like doody doody I missed my mom and dad I bet Clem How far is Savannah?
Pretty far.
Oh.
Aww.
Uh-oh.
Getting real ominous.
I love you, Barry.
What did he do?
Or maybe didn't do.
Whatever.
What occurred to be in the police car?
Hmm.
His wife do.
Hey, get up.
Oh, how you go, Zain, and itchy.
Well, you slept in a barn, little lady.
Lucky you don't have spiders in your hair.
But I bet your daddy scared him all the way, huh?
Smells like Miki.
My name is Miki.
I'm Kenny.
Dad, we're in a little offense.
There's a tractor and everything.
Is that an actual child actor?
Because it sounds like it.
He can't enunciate.
old friends call them duck though duck where do parents name their kids duck we're from Fort Lauderdale we were on our way back before things up and went bananas Fort Lauderdale duck word is you were on your way to Macon my family's from there well Macon's on the way and personally I'd appreciate the company of a guy who can knock a couple of heads together if he has to oh I'll ask the uh maybe maybe yeah we'll see how things shake out with this herschel guy yeah yeah good luck with that he's a hard ass honey duck this is lee and uh what's the girl's name clementine clementine god is a very pretty name thanks well we should get to work we've all seen what those things can do out there the faster we get this fence up the better story i want to build a fence yeah well i need a good foreman you can sit on the tractor and yell at me whenever i take a water break on the tractor cool duck and i will hop to it sid yeah looks like sid i can keep an eye on your little girl here on the porch we
can visit visit what do you mean what do you mean by that
oh time for me to to mosey let's see what's got what we got going on here on the farm Look at Duck.
Be sure to check in with everyone you've met so far.
How you doing, Duck?
Good.
I'm going to drive the tractor.
I'm the foreman.
Lift with your back, Sean.
I think this is an actual child.
Boy, is that like this kid?
I'm going to drive the tractor.
How you doing, Duck?
Good.
I'm going to drive the tractor.
I'm the foreman.
Lift with your back, Sean.
I'm looking at it.
him oh he's waving at me this guy's so much whimsy you know how to drive it sure don't I can give you a hell of a critique he's doing his best I'm good this is does not seem like a fortified enough of a fence I think Sean's still working on that fence it needs to be much taller hey Lee need a hand need a hand that'd be Great.
If you could cut those two-byes to length, that sure speed things up.
Sure thing.
What is your super chat saying?
My dad doesn't know how bad it is.
No, he doesn't.
I saw a guy and I'm going to kill a kid.
A boy.
Just shot him right in the face.
Oh my god!
Was the boy one of the walkers?
I don't even know.
He was either attacking the guy or asking for help.
Oh my god!
even hesitate he just turned put the barrel of the gun right between the kid's eyes and pulled the trigger you don't see things like that it's not like in the movies they don't fall like you think did you have to do it do what kill have you had to off one yet oh that bastard what girls brains in whoa I couldn't do that She was on- Sean won't forget that.
I had to!
Dad just wants to keep the family safe and thinks inviting people in is a bigger threat than whatever's out there.
She was on top of me!
How's your family?
My parents are in Macon.
My brother and parents are in Macon.
Oh man, I hope so too.
Maybe it's not too bad there.
Is that far from Atlanta?
That's probably all I need cut for now.
Thanks.
Like, is it...
Like, are we going on an epic journey there?
Like, Lord of the Rings?
Or is it really close?
Oh, it's kind of a bit.
Do you think this thing will keep about...
Three to four hour drive!
I'm planning on coming back through on a fortification pass, if you will.
We'll lock this place up, good.
Okay.
Good luck with that.
Why is he like...
Why is it so sporadic?
What?
Okay.
You...
What is he doing?
Wait, they got a dog?
Wait, can I see it?
Where's the puppy?
Wait, they got chickens?
Can I see them?
I love that I can moonwalk.
Okay, this is a serious game.
Right?
I don't want to be joking around the whole time, but...
Yeah, he's got some sick moves.
I like how he just slept in the barn.
There really are...
This is a pretty big house.
There were no...
There were no guest rooms at all, or...
You have such pretty hair.
It gets lots of tangles.
Aw.
This is a big house!
There wasn't one room that we could sleep in.
The attic?
Hey there, girls.
um what do you do how was the city you two actually look relaxed no say how was the city how did you handle getting through the city yeah kenny just drove we passed so many people that needed help and we just passed people over some just master on the dance floor it's okay it's fine you don't have to say anymore i want to go home tomorrow but even then i can't take away the things we dock went through oh don't you want to go back to the moment before you knew about all of this uh anybody in their right mind would families and barbecues and beers with good friends that could mean something else to him too you know before the things that happened to him as well right with those gone what's the point hmm what do you do so uh what do you do when corpses aren't walking around I'm a veterinarian back in Fort Lauderdale like Herschel here except more with dogs and cats and not horses what is it that you do Lee she has like an accent used to teach up at the University of Georgia we need to
hope that we can go back to our jobs soon Lee back to normal it can't stay like this
oh yeah my mistake we'll all be home soon Yeah.
I like her eyeshadow.
It's so pretty.
You two actually look relaxed.
I think we're doing just fine.
The J word.
Clementine was just telling me about first grade.
Oh, um, how's that?
It's easy.
Well, yeah.
Hey.
So, you good?
Anyway, it's almost like we didn't see people eating each other for the past three days.
Stupid girl can't pass first grade.
Back in a bit.
Okay, Lee.
as a first grader.
Uh, duh, stupid dummy.
It's first graders for babies.
Seems like those two are getting along.
Aw.
Okay, let's talk to Kenny.
Kicks, oh wait, what's that say?
Lake something kicks bass.
Wait, I want to look at Kenny first.
It seems like an all right, dude.
come from now that I think about it where did this where did Kenny come from hey there Kenny Kenny what's your plan so what's your family's plan get back on down to Lauderdale and let this mess get sorted out oh government will start handing out shots and the National Guard will do its thing on the odd chance things got too bad we could hop on my boat I guess you've a boat i'm a commercial fisherman catch a man dolphin whatever's biting and paying kacha wouldn't be wild about it but the boat's not that bad you learned about kenny's boat if he were a real florida man he would not be wearing a lake shirt that that guy would have a sticker that says salt life which i often used to think would say slut life I thought,
wow, people are really comfortable with just, with just, with just letting that info out.
Yeah, he would not be on the lake.
He would be on the, on the ocean.
Need any help?
No, I think I got it.
Okay.
Do you need any help?
What do you mean?
I mean and taking care of that little girl.
You know what you're doing?
You got kids of your own?
Uh, I have no idea.
I have no idea what I'm doing.
At least you're honest.
I am.
Shit.
Better than I was when Duck showed up.
You'll figure it out.
How's your son doing?
Good, I think.
Kachie's got a sister up in Memphis.
We were coming back from visiting her.
Casino in my slot life.
I thought he was kidnapping him.
I was on the fucker in about two seconds and Christ Just lucky I was there Glad I'm not alone in reading We saw a lot of bodies before we stumbled upon Herschel's Yeah, my friend would both read them the wrong way Ain't nothing gonna phase us See you Okay You showed an interest in his family What else is there now?
I talked with everybody, no?
Can I go inside?
Hey Clementine, check this out.
Pretty sick, huh?
Duck.
Hey duck.
Gosh, someone from Florida wouldn't name their kid duck, huh?
That's such a Florida...
Oh!
Mr. Mann's out here.
I always read those at Slut Live, yeah!
Kenny today, I wouldn't stand for your lack of honesty last night.
I'm not sure I follow.
Uh-oh.
I ain't dumb.
I caught you in that lie last night about who you were with in that car.
And honestly, I don't even want to know.
How'd you get out of Atlanta?
Oh, I got a ride.
I got a ride and then I was in a wreck.
I walked until your boy found me.
Yeah.
Well, you're no worse for where.
This farm's a nice plot of land.
Had you told me 20 years ago I'd still be doing this, I would have told you that you were full of crap.
Never was a plan.
Having a place like this.
It was in the family, and I guess so was I.
Family's important.
It's all that matters.
Right, Jill.
Do you agree with that?
Was brought up too?
Yes.
Where's your family now?
Parents?
wife girlfriend uh my parents are in makin my parents are in makin with my brother well i hope they're all right you're in florida but now you've got this little girl to take care you're a florida man is it you just stumbled up on her yes actually that's uh i was looking for help in her house yeah i was looking for help in her house
it's true it's honest give you a piece of advice what uh what is it what is it i don't know who you are what you did let's say things don't get better back in the cities or they get worse before they do you're gonna have to depend on the honesty of strangers if you're gonna make it and if those same people get to questioning yours you're gonna be in trouble oh and i'd start checking the attitude,
friend.
I don't have an attitude!
Go!
I'll get my gun.
Oh my god, already?
Oh,
shoot.
Wait, I have to save one?
You chose to save Duck.
Wait, I shouldn't have saved...
Oh, wait.
Oh.
I should have... I should have saved the other guy.
Take me!
Yeah, let his dad save him.
Kick him.
I'll punch him.
Okay, now let's save Sean.
Oh yeah, we gotta do that.
Oh my god.
Ah!
Oh no!
Oh!
Sean!
Oh, Sean.
At least he's pinned.
Kenny, you coward.
What the hell?
Ran off with this kid.
I saved the kid because I felt like he was weaker.
Oh.
And that he...
Get the fuck out of here!
And that Sean could take care of himself.
But Sean did have two guys on him.
Sorry.
Your son is alive.
You don't get to be sorry.
And you...
I thought I could save both.
I didn't even try to help.
I'm so...
I thought I could...
I thought I could help them, but...
I did!
Look at him.
You thought wrong.
And now...
Is there a way to save both of them or no?
Just go.
Get out and never come back.
Maybe he should have yelled that...
Wait, okay, so what are the order of operations here?
Because...
Um, the man's leg was stuck.
did did did did duck run him over at the same time as the zombies come in he should have yelled you got that ride to make it if you want oh no you have to only pick one oh you can't save sean
oh press x to sean i was thinking of two sure sure So Duck ran him over, and then he should have yelled, and we would have helped him, and then the zombies come.
This is as far as we're going.
Like, like, I fear that Sean was not able to be, there was no saving him.
Drug.
Jason.
Look.
Duck, you killed a man.
Hey there.
Oh, no.
You friendly?
No, no.
Trucks run out of gas.
I hate these people have no survival instincts.
I think I'm going...
Oh, gosh.
Ah!
Why would you yell?
Sorry.
I don't mean to laugh.
It's just...
Run!
Yeah!
We can't.
We can't take risks like this.
And we can't just let people die either.
When I say that door stays shut no matter what, I fucking mean it.
Oh.
We don't know who these people are.
They could be dangerous.
Ah.
They couldn't let them right to us.
We have kids.
Where the hell is your humanity?
We have kids with us.
Yeah.
I see one little girl.
I'm dead.
What is it?
I have to pee.
And then Duck is...
I go out there again in a second.
i bet you just go then just go oh don't be mean i didn't be wait no they've got kids lily those things outside don't care maybe you should go join him then you'll have something wait what happened to duck god damn it lily you have to control these people carly and glenn just ran out there i don't give a flying fuck uh she's not wrong she's not wrong they took a risk yes we did yeah and we appreciate it now let's settle down yeah holy shit son of a bitch one of them is bitten what oh no he wasn't bitten he wasn't bitten hell he wasn't well he was we have to end this wait was he over my dead body well dig one hole no i'm cleaning him up there's no bite he's fine don't you fucking people get it we've already seen this happen we let someone with a bite stay in and we all end up bitten shut up we gotta throw him out or smash his head here kenny stop him what do we do about this guy Oh,
I uh, um, it's just boy.
It's kick his ass.
You need let's reason with the guy.
We reason with him Wait, you didn't side with Kenny.
Wait, wait, what do you mean?
I'm trying to reason with the guy and you shut the fuck up They will find us and they will get in here and none of this will fucking matter.
Wait a second We're about to be trapped in here with one of those things what the hell are you talking about he's bitten he's not bitten please stop this it's upsetting him oh i'm upsetting him uh upsetting is getting eaten alive dad we get it it's a big deal what if this was your daughter never would have happened she's not some snot-nosed toddler okay she's united states air force you and her your kid should be in the air force just worry about duck Yeah,
there's someone in there.
It's just locked keys behind the counter wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait wait No, no, no.
Hey, I'm not the bad guy here.
I'm checking out for my daughter.
No, you're just the guy arguing for killing a kid He's covered in muck.
She'll find the bite watch she won't go to the bathroom and rinse him off.
I don't first thing He'll do is sink his teeth into his mom's face.
There's a bathroom right there When she's dead he'll probably pounce on your little girl she'll turn fast then we do what you said no it's just a ball game it's a little boy I think we can handle it a little boy be an uncontrollable man-eater okay that's gonna happen it is and we're tossing him out now uh hit him yeah hit him knock this guy out Jesus oh Kenny
Oh my god, why did we fall?
What just happened?
Is it our leg?
Oh my gosh, wait, I can't see anything.
Uh, rescue Clementine.
I'm going!
No!
Concussion?
Guys?
I did believe...
How was I supposed to save her?
Oh my god, oh my god.
Sorry, Clementine.
Clementine has plot armor.
She can't die.
I don't know.
Thank God for whatever it is.
Is Glenn like Glenn from the show?
That was stupid.
That was...
Dad!
Uh...
Was he the bitten, bud?
Was he the one bitten?
No, don't be crazy.
It's his heart.
My pills.
Nitroglycerin pills?
Yes, we're out.
We've been trying to get into the pharmacy since we got here.
Please try to get in there.
Behind the counter where the pills are.
Well, why would I be able to?
We'll do it somehow.
We'll get in there somehow.
Thank you so much.
Bitten in his heart.
We need nitroglycerin pills.
Please get in there.
I'll keep an eye on my dad.
Did you guys not go to the bathroom at all?
How did you not know that there was a thing in there?
I'm starting to think this drugstore isn't a permanent solution.
You're right.
This ain't exactly Fort Knox.
What do you suggest?
We need as much gas as possible so we can all get out of downtown Macon.
Oh, we're in Macon.
Then I'll head out and get gas.
There's a motel not too far from here.
Out towards the end of Peachtree.
I'll work my way towards it and then loop back siphoning what I can.
They picked a P-corner.
Um, you know your way around town?
You know your way around?
local born and raised okay if you're gonna do that here's a walkie-talkie if you get in a tight spot oh cute hopefully you won't need it cool clementine's got the other one check in with her and get back here as soon as you can easily thank you my dad's larry keep a good eye on him these boys will work on getting you your medicine that's right and you you keep an eye on that front door you're our lookout who is this guy you got it it dug and i'm carly i didn't even know Carly you'll shift in with Doug when he needs it for now.
Where did you come from?
You're a good shot and I'd like to keep it that way You got it boss now get him those pills.
Oh my gosh.
Maro.
Thank you so much for that.
I'll go say well, thank you Where did Doug come from?
Oh gosh, I didn't save Clementine.
I damaged this place didn't get looted.
Yeah Okay, well we got perfumes and
Family planning Ooh, la la What's this?
The corkboard.
Easter egg hunt.
The IT.
The it.
The it's guy.
I've heard of seeing anything.
Nothing, luckily.
Want to step outside, have a look around?
No.
I'm not suicidal yet.
No, the gate out there is closed.
We can hang out in front of the store and be fine i i don't think i'm gonna do that uh not now uh not right now all right let me know if you want to why i guess okay hello what are you messing around with there i can't get it to work though here let me have a look he's been here the whole time oh um did you try turning it on and off
Does it need batteries?
Did she not check that?
There are no batteries in this thing.
What now?
Stupid woman.
I know that there are no batteries in that thing.
Yeah, of course.
I mean, yeah.
No.
I can try to find some.
Needs too.
Thanks.
I wouldn't even really know what to look for.
She's got a good shot, but she's got no brains.
How I like them.
years we got some food looks like nobody got a chance to donate anything before this all went dang clementine i'm sorry i missed the qte are you mad at me hey there hi can i get you anything get you anything i'm okay maybe i'm a little hungry did you pee i'll see about that go piss girl any word from glenn any word from glenn nothing is he okay Yeah,
I think so.
You're doing a good job.
Miss Phantom.
So, um...
Are you okay?
What?
Uh, yeah, yeah.
I'm fine.
I just, uh...
I'm good.
That's good.
Yeah, I think so.
Uh, being good is good, despite the circumstances.
Yep.
We'll sit tight.
Have you played telltale games before?
Energy bar.
Oh, we can give this to...
Is he okay?
I think he's...
Holy cow!
Oh, he was grabbing...
Oh my gosh.
Give...
It's not much, but here you go.
There you go, a little energy bar.
Of course.
You took care of Clementine.
Yes, I did.
Wait, we can take more energy bars.
This one's for me.
Dental needs.
Shaving needs.
I've never seen, like, a store that says hair needs.
Like, it just usually says, like, hair.
You know.
Okay.
Alive inside.
Oh, my gosh.
Don't dead.
Open inside.
How's he doing?
I'm not sure I got your name.
I'm Lee.
Lily.
My dad's Larry.
I was just doing what I had to earlier Everyone was Now his heart's acting up again And I'm powerless to do anything And that violence before A lot of good telltale games But didn't help What's wrong with him?
What's wrong with him?
He's got a heart condition He takes nitroglycerin tablets pretty regularly I've seen a few bad attacks That he couldn't get over And needed to go to the hospital Yeah, that's not really an option right now I'm just trying to keep him relaxed between you and me doky-doby who do you think would turn into zombie first I can't I'm dead so good luck everybody else um what do you think about all this you're from here you're from here I work at Warner Robbins the Air Force base oh oh yeah he did mention that just mechanical admin stuff I deal with a bunch of shitheads and bureaucrats all day sometimes a plane if I'm lucky you I work up at UGA.
UGA.
Uh, was anyone here when you guys got to the pharmacy?
Was anyone here when you guys got here?
No, this place was pretty wrecked.
We pulled a couple of bodies out of the office.
Are you okay?
Yeah, I'm fine.
Did you know anybody here?
Oh.
Yeah, the owners, they were, uh, we were close.
Oh!
I'm sorry.
We found an older couple in the office.
them out in case they weren't really dead
um yeah he's got a temper he's got a temper ah fuck you yeah he doesn't mean it it's just that
we've got kids here families we've got kids here families he and i are a family i'm just saying some people can't handle a temper like that hell Well, he seems like you can't it's just his way don't make him the reason everything's screwed She's getting mad at me.
Oh, where's her mom?
Savannah, I think oh You guys aren't together.
Oh, no, I'm not her dad.
Why is everybody so weird about like getting out of Atlanta?
She's been surviving by herself I think the girl's parents didn't make it.
Oh Like it I heard an answering message They were in Savannah.
She was home with a sitter.
It wasn't good.
Stranger danger, maybe.
She's lucky to have you.
Is it strange in this kind of situation?
I feel like everybody just kind of like finds each other.
I don't think it would be so strange to be like, yeah, I found a person on...
Just kind of surviving.
In this kind of story.
Hmm.
But, you know.
Kind of since it's...
recent i guess so i know everything went to so fast what do you think about all this what do you think about all this what is there to think the dead are up walking around eating people and turning them into more more of them yeah i mean jesus we need to stick together and get through this i never really understood i'm gonna get back to him sounds good never really and lee yeah it was a crazy situation and you froze before with that thing coming out of the bathroom oh yeah just don't beat yourself up over don't call me out we stick together and we'll be okay the dead are walking no like okay what I don't understand is like usually like okay is zombies in this case.
If, if, if, if something is, if something becomes a zombie, then, then, sit, like, I guess it depends on what.
I don't know.
Like, what's the point of infecting other things?
you don't eat the people to like consume you eat to is it just to spread but then yeah they hungry they're just hungry it's like a parasite that needs a host but then eventually and then also how long are the zombies supposed to live for i remember in the walking dead there were zombies that were like living for years.
I mean, dead for years.
Living dead for years.
That's so confusing.
Anyway, okay.
I don't understand how zombies work.
We can't let anything happen to Ducky.
Ducky!
Hey, Lee.
Maybe punching him wasn't such a good idea there were worse plans says the guy who didn't get punched in the mouth oh well it's your kid I don't appreciate your support thank you Lee how's duck doing wait this place has snow cones and Sundays oh and what is a specials specials how's duck doing it's okay it was just a shock we're lucky as hell nobody got nabbed on the way in here little kid how's she doing how much of the zombies eat you unless they eat your brains oh wait uh her family is wait who'd they ask about well her family's dead so that's awful lee oh yeah well she seems to be handling herself all right she's just a little girl okay lee says she spent days on her own that takes tough so it has been days no idea what sort of emotional damage is happening to her every second we slept in the car for days what's the plan what's the plan hang tight i suppose seems pretty dangerous out there so we ought to wait for things to clear up you said your family is from here in makin that's
right where are they should we go looking for them oh they own this place wait is that what he meant they uh owned this place they uh pulled some bodies out of the office before we got here oh no that's what he meant gone oh sweetie cat they were good people i wasn't around much but yeah they did that's so sad so he didn't tell them that it was his parents but it was his parents so sad are you guys all right we're just fine considering how about you duck All bad throughout.
Lee, you got a second?
Duck has... Duck...
Duck has trauma in his eyes.
Yeah.
We didn't even try to save him.
That blood is on our hands, you know?
It happened pretty fast.
It happened pretty fast, I guess.
But I can't stop seeing him in my head.
Oh, you're the one who ran away.
We killed that boy.
You?
We could have saved him.
You ran away!
Why is he getting bad at me?
You think you do when you look back on it, but in a moment, when things are really out of control, you don't have any choice.
I guess.
Can he go back to Florida?
Console?
Try to let it go.
Wee.
I don't want this guy's loyalty, though.
I don't think he is very loyal.
Wait, what was that?
The Walking Dead doesn't have zombie media, so it's new to them.
Oh, is he going to see his parents?
That's so sad.
Wolf Among Us.
That would be a good time since second season is potentially releasing soon.
I'll look into it.
I saw some other people talking about it too.
Thank you.
can't i can't think about them in here oh clementine what he's doing in here girl how you doing okay okay so sad oh there's a photo over there no no no
happy birthday nerdy laundry
find anything oh my god
Just a picture.
Just a picture of whoever was here.
I know who you are.
Oh.
You're Lee Everett.
You're a professor at Athens who killed a state senator who was sleeping with your wife.
This is your parents' store.
Folks around town know the owner's son got himself a life sentence, but I'm a reporter for W-A-B-E in Atlanta.
I paid attention to that trial.
Maybe you're a murderer, but I don't really care.
Frankly, that's a skill that might come in handy.
Did you tell anyone out there who you were or that you were tied to this place it's the apocalypse who cares the world is ending out there who cares who I am yeah if you don't think people will find any reason to turn on you especially when the shit hits the fan you're insane whatever you seem like an okay guy and the last thing we need is drama out there you've got this little girl to take care of and look don't make me wrong on this I don't plan to good because if this lasts longer than a few days and you're a detriment to the group then we'd have a problem i'm not a detriment i'll just keep it to myself
we'll be nice thanks thanks don't worry about it whoa she likes me what if she fell for me during the trial
wait oh we're go legal go legal go legal
No, take it, take it.
There we go.
That's not true, Mr. I think you definitely need stuff.
My parents came in here hoping to survive.
It looks like one of them was her.
Trying to be a hero, maybe.
Or protect her, at least.
So sad.
Look at the alley.
Wait, is he gonna move this?
Please say no.
This door leads to the back alley.
I don't think we should do that.
Oh, legal.
Trying to get to, like, a different...
Is there...
Maybe?
Move the pallet?
What's that?
Oh, nice.
This is my dad's cane.
Oh.
He'd zip around here on it from time to time.
Was he sick?
I thought it was like a...
I didn't think it was a can.
I thought it was a...
Like a ballot.
This place better than any guard dog ever could.
Plus, he knew how to make it look cool.
Like you had.
No!
My dad gave it to me.
So cute!
See, dads are smart like that.
Carly just knew Lee was the favor.
Yeah, exactly.
Door to pharmacy.
Wait, why is it blocked, though?
I oughta clear a path to opening that door.
I think there's something in there.
We gotta clear this door for when we find the keys.
Well, then move it.
Better get this door clear, huh?
Can I help?
She's so sweet!
Sweet, sweet, clementa.
Um, things have been scary, huh?
Things have been scary, huh?
Yeah.
It's not good.
I don't know why everyone...
one is crazy neither do i clementine nobody does the living dead i think so i bet my dad does okay here we go no she's so strong do you have kids no you don't have a family no oh let's all talk about that do you play Let's not talk about that.
Do you play sports?
I play soccer, but I don't really like it.
Why not?
I'm not crazy about it either.
All right, a little further.
Leave!
Hole!
I think there's something in there.
I'm scared.
Why don't you want to talk about your family?
Do they like hate you?
Um, because like I, um...
Because they're dead.
I hope not It's just complicated Well, apparently he murdered a senator That's kind of crazy This guy murdered a senator And he was being transported in a cop car with only one cop I feel like they would give him like crazy treatment Um Because they're dead Because they're dead Oh Oh Oh I'm sorry.
Oh.
You didn't know.
I'm just sorry for being mean.
Oh, no.
Clever Tart.
Look, my family's gone and I just wish things would have been different.
Yeah.
He was a state senator.
Let's not go crazy.
Okay.
Oh, shoot.
I guess let's finish moving the desk.
I didn't notice it had a timer.
Sometimes they have timers and sometimes they don't.
I'm so sorry.
Okay.
Let me just...
Are you okay?
I hurt my finger.
Is it bleeding?
A little.
Hope there's no zombie blood on it.
On the...
I'll find you a bandage.
On the table.
Bandage in here.
Nothing.
Wait, there's a bandage over here.
Give to her.
My crap, story mode!
That's a telltale.
It hurt.
Oh, let's see if we can do something about it.
That thing bled fast.
Oh Let's get this cut covered up.
Yes, please.
Senator Armstrong
Hey Lee Yeah, what if my parents come home and I'm not there?
They'll find us they'll uh track us down.
Yeah, don't worry Yeah, okay, but we should keep a lookout.
I've got my walkie-talkie in case they try that way Stay close to me and to them.
Okay She got bit by a desk.
She's gonna become one.
Yeah That's the door to the pharmacy.
We should be able to find tools for Larry in there Larry pills here It's locked.
We need to track down the keys if we're gonna help Larry.
Where would the keys be?
I thought they be in the drawer they're really not remote to my dad's tv oh he took it oh oh the tv we can actually turn it on that's what i figured uh minecraft story mode i think i saw doki play that right isn't there something with like the pig it's all i know about it because of her
Um, have you heard from Glenn?
Have you heard from Glenn?
Not in a little while.
Doki did play it.
It's pretty good, really?
How's your fix?
It's okay.
Thanks for fixing it.
She's so sweet.
I'm gonna keep looking around.
Okay.
Where could the key be?
What am I missing?
Not in here?
Want to head back into the drugstore with me?
Okay.
Yeah.
You're not bad, right?
I...
Why are you asking me that?
That lady said you killed someone.
Was that because he was one of the things trying to eat you?
It's complicated.
Sometimes things happen or you do things and you can't explain them.
Let's, uh...
back to the others he was eating my wife
yeah yeah can i go into the bathroom where could the key be
you're a pretty good shot well you don't fuck with a reporter especially one that's three days out from her last cup of coffee.
She sounds like a reporter.
She has like that reporter voice.
The reporter accent.
I'm looking for batteries for your radio.
Oh, I am?
I am.
I'm still looking for batteries for that day.
Thanks.
I appreciate it.
Story of the century here, huh?
Yeah, and I've got shit for recording equipment.
And from the looks of it, there isn't going to be any shortage of first-hand accounts.
Unless everybody dies.
that's right well until some piece of shit politicians yank our funding and I hit the blogosphere vlogosphere you seem to handle yourself pretty well really never heard anyone I can't tell use that my news editor was eaten about five feet away from me and I would have joined her if it wasn't for that dorky guy on watch over there I'm sorry she was an asshole what was his name you know Dennis that guy saved that guy saved him yeah can you believe it those creeps or or ghouls or whatever the hell they are doug they were pulling our van apart and that guy doug just came to the rescue you could never tell who the heroic ones are gonna be i suppose he's kind of cute in that parent's basement sort of way huh you'd be so judgmental oh my gosh he looked adorable to me they're saying that he's like he never leaves the basement my goodness how'd you end up here we drove up to cover the cherry blossom festival real hard hitting stuff wow so it's worth it i better get back to it yep okay so we're
looking for keys and a battery don't mention it just remember what i said yeah i will hey there this is glenn and uh i'm kind of in a jam here uh little girl if you're there can you put your daddy on the phone or on the talkie or whatever here you go what's up so i'm down at that motor inn and well i'm stuck stuck yeah i uh saw a chance to get some supplies for the group and a bunch of the roman ones got the jump on i'm hiding over here but they won't leave what's up glenn's trapped down at the motor inn hey glenn we're gonna talk it over and send a group to come get you all right we are awesome i'll sit tight till then sounds good Oh.
Hold on to this until we get Glenn back, okay?
I'll take good care of it.
What do you think?
I think Doug's not great around zombies.
Why?
Doug is a hero.
We know this.
I'll take Carly and her dead eye down to the motor end, get Glenn, and get back here as fast as I can.
If that's what you want to do, somebody's got to.
Yeah.
I'm in.
Always avoiding using the word zombie.
Doesn't sound too bad there right now.
Let me know as soon as you want to head out.
I guess because it sounds kind of cartoonish.
Um, the key?
and the the battery oh I found a battery gamers don't look down
battery this battery should fit the radio zombie is copyright thanks okay one more battery wait what's this greeting cards I don't think I checked over here no I'm sorry to hear your loved was eaten by the living dead cards specifically walking dead because the graphic novel is like that so the word zombie like oh another battery nice need to get back to fort lauderdale we'll do our damnedest why do why i don't understand like that kind of mentality where you're just like we we have to get back to the place where we're from like i think everything's all gone to hell
buddy I got another battery and here's another one should be able to get it to work now thank you so much for that cuz over there you thank you thank you it's still not working yeah I can't figure it out did you turn it on go ahead did you press the on button
wait the volume is literally off
Oh, wait, it actually isn't working.
Wait, did she put them in wrong?
Oh, women!
Oh, God!
No!
You fixed it.
The estimated death toll continues to skyrocket.
W-A-B-E argues you to stay indoors and avoid any contact with individuals you suspect may have been exposed the station is okay in the event of a full uh my my producer's telling me we have to get off here steve oh my god god god bless you all
so scary okay now we gotta find the keys where did i not look it's i feel like they gotta be in here I'm trapped.
There we go.
Oh, wait.
I see an energy bar.
I'm just going to keep taking these.
Yeah.
And then we'll go get Glenn.
Hopefully he's okay.
Can I search the bed?
What are the odds the radio fixed just then?
I'm trying to be a hero, maybe.
I'll protect her at least.
Give one to Ducky.
That kid doesn't need one.
Kids...
I thought this was a safe.
Where can we find it?
Hmm.
I really don't see anything else.
Do you want a hint?
What are we looking for?
We're looking for the key to the pharmacy.
I didn't want to go...
I didn't want to get it until I...
Or, like, go to Glenn until I got the key.
because I'm not sure if I will be able to find it.
Check with Doug.
Wait, does he have it?
Wait, maybe he'll tell me where the people are, the bodies he took out.
Oh, wait, Doug.
Oh, maybe they moved them outside.
My parents.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Try to get some rest, Hunt.
How can I with those things out there?
Doug.
How are we doing?
Good.
Want to go have a look around outside?
Okay.
Look, he looks normal what do they mean like oh it looks like a basement dweller
how are we supposed to get outside
they just eat as far as i can tell that's all i care about yeah whatever's left comes back as one of them yeah and then you go bald like that lady I think it might be more than a couple days before all this gets sorted out oh my God a couple days that's that's real hopeful oh
shut up I can use the remote oh maybe that's how we get out boarded up windows yeah that's a hasty fortification job over there Yeah, it didn't work.
Dom, no, welcome back.
Thank you.
I was gonna...
I can't reach that brick.
Oh, just kidding.
I was gonna take it.
Did you guys try to get in there and get weapons?
I did, but it was too risky.
Then a bunch of guys showed up and they tried.
And what happened?
I think they're most of who you see wandering around out there.
Oh, oh.
I don't want to do it just yet, but...
Open the lock.
That's crazy.
It's a combination lock.
Ah, fuel!
Okay.
Well, I don't see the keys out.
Where did they put the bodies?
That place is full of TVs and electronics.
Should I do it?
I think it...
There we go.
Your favorite show is on.
You know what I could do?
What's that?
Go, Doug.
Go with your socks and your sandals.
It's universal.
I could program it to work with those TVs across the street.
Let's just hope the power is still on.
Yeah.
You can just do that?
You can?
I memorized all the codes when I was in AV.
Let's try.
He's hacking.
Don't have your hand outside.
Well fucking done, dog.
Woo!
Dog nonsense might save a life.
Who's to say it already hasn't?
Whoa!
That guy is so gnarly.
I've got a few of them to take notice.
Hacker man!
Oh, they don't care.
Not enough.
Aw, man.
We tried.
AV Club for the win.
Oh, yeah.
Any idea where the pharmacy keys might be?
We searched high and low inside before you guys got here.
They weren't on the old couple we could have in the office.
Are you okay?
If the keys aren't in the drugstore, you think they could be out of here?
We now live in a world where getting up and walking ways and actual possibilities.
Right.
How'd you end up here?
I moved here to live with my uncle.
He does tech stuff and it just made sense.
So you're local.
You probably knew the owners of this place.
No, not really.
I've only been here a couple months and I spend a lot of time.
On the computer?
No, just doing my own thing.
Let a man live!
I grew up here.
I've been trying to get home since the day it came back.
So you probably knew the owners then?
Uh, you could say that.
Good people.
He was a V-Tuber.
Doug is the original V-Tuber.
I was just about to say, imagine being that guy.
Wait.
Oh, no.
Is that his brother?
Look at the one trapped over there.
Your brother.
oh shit what do you know that guy yeah he could be a drugstore he could be a drugstore employee yeah yeah so you're saying he might have the pharmacy keys I think so oh my gosh that's scary he might have the pharmacy keys I don't know could be anybody you know they start rotting and get all cheetah up and shut
Oh my god!
Look at the uniform though.
He could have worked at the drugstore and died with keys in his pocket.
It would take a lot of effort to make it safe enough to go out there and see if he has the keys.
It would.
If we could somehow prove that he worked here, I think it'd be worth it.
I got the evidence.
I'll see what I can find.
I have the evidence.
That guy over there has the keys.
sure i found this in the office favorite zombie movie the photo worked here the key is being on him is as good a bed as we can make yeah i agree just need to figure out how to get out there and get them you wouldn't need long right just a few seconds maybe there's a way to distract them and buy you
Maybe if we...
I can't reach that brick.
I can't reach it.
Man, that's a hasty fortification job over there.
I was gonna say...
Yeah, it didn't work.
Maybe like throwing the brick at the window?
Um...
The cane?
Oh, the cane to get the brick!
Let's head back inside.
You're right, you're right.
thinking everybody kiwi welcome to Babyship thank you yeah if you haven't seen ponti pool before it's not like your average zombie movie i recommend it very much it's uh quite cool that's the door to the pharmacy we should be able to find pills for larry in there
Grab it.
Grab the cane.
Use the cane.
Take the cane.
Cane?
Cane.
Take the cane.
Get the cane.
Grab can.
Grab.
Hand out.
Touch can.
Can.
You can't take the cane because I...
Oh my gosh.
Wait.
I got one guide or several guide.
Okay, well, we definitely have to use something to get the brick.
Open the...
I mean, we could unlock it and get the brick and then...
I'm scared.
Okay, let's just go.
I don't think there's anything else.
Talk to Carly.
look around outside oh wait talk to uh not now not now wait what's carly saying
yes hey carly oh oh uh no not yet not yet not yet no are you okay that radio sign off didn't sound too good are you okay i'm reading the synopsis upon people of sorry they couldn't remember i've seen this movie yeah you don't have to be yeah you don't have to be okay i'm sure some people got out voice acted maybe they're all being rescued then again maybe not it is i carly
it's so wonderful you want to go have a look around outside let's have a look around okay oh okay i'm gonna i'm gonna open it it just saved so i think we can try you want to get this door open about that yeah you do have the combo no you don't have did anyone ever have it look man there were a lot of those things trying to get in here then how did you open it for us to the street well we're also partied to some egregious fire code violations wait how did you open it to let us in wait what then how do we get out wait huh wait those things Those things like TV.
Those things like TV.
Or at least the sound of it.
Yeah.
If they were louder, we might be able to clear the street.
That's why I want to take the brick and throw it and then...
Those TVs are on.
And I'm sure they're making a lot of noise behind that glass.
Use the remote on it.
Oh, on this, yeah.
Peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep, peep.
Open sesame.
That won't work.
That was cute.
Just like the cover that's releasing tomorrow.
I know, Don.
Lee's brother.
That's messed up.
A few seconds of searching it.
We'll know if he has a keys.
That's so messed up.
His whole family is dead.
Garbanzo beans.
There's so many of them.
Let's head back inside.
Okay.
I think he can reach that brick.
I think he's just being late.
I guess...
I'm not quite sure what to do.
Grab the brick.
It won't levy!
He says that he can't reach it!
So...
Is there something that shows what the code is for the lock?
There's also the door to the alley, but I don't think that would do us any good.
Oh, wait.
Actually, we can't even look at that door anymore.
And there's nothing in the...
I don't think there's anything here at all.
Wait, does this work now?
No.
That's what I figured.
Is there a book on the counter?
Nope.
Here's a first aid kit.
I don't know if we get Glenn first or after.
we open the pharmacy and all.
Ice cream menu?
It's all melted now.
I could give him...
No, he doesn't need...
He doesn't need anything.
Oh, wait.
Okay, there's more stuff to look at.
Okay, good, good.
I don't remember them very well.
Who?
Okay.
Greeting cards.
Is there anything here that would say the code?
Oh, my family.
you got them codes you got them codes anyone's got them codes hey hey I'm gonna get back to him sounds good oh okay
code boomer
how's your finger?
how's your finger Cleo?
good it doesn't hurt so much anymore she's so brave I know I'm not your dad switching in from work since I'm on the overnight shift until October oh my gosh Eric good luck excited to experience it for the first time with you yeah I know I'm not your dad but if you need anything I'm your guy okay same same oh no you know we're gonna try to take care of each other yes deal let me know if you need anything You checked on Clementine.
See, she knows that I got her back.
She knows, she knows.
Anything else?
Looks like nobody got a chance to donate anything before this all went down.
Anything?
ATM?
It's got numbers on it?
It's not damaged.
Glad this place didn't get looted.
Use the axe.
Where was an axe at?
Newspaper.
Maybe here?
okay I guess I think we have to go get Glenn I think we gotta go get Glenn people are jumping ahead hey stop jumping ahead you ready to head out you got it you yeah yeah let's go I don't you know this old man is not important enough to me to have to try so hard you really do go bald when you become a zombie
did you see that oh that's him be ready to shoot no I think it's Glenn oh man I'm glad you Jesus, Glenn.
That was really loud.
Can we get out of here before any of these things notice us?
I thought it would be more gameplay.
Oh.
No way, we gotta go now.
Listen, I was out here looking for gas.
And then, up there in the corner room, I heard crying coming from inside.
Oh.
Who is it?
It's a girl.
We talked and she got frightened.
I was trying to get in and help her and she started yelling and saying I was bitten.
What?
I wasn't and that's when all these guys came out of the forest lost cause next and I ended up hiding in the ice machine lucky you now let's go we can't just leave her damn right we can you guys are suicidal over a girl I'm saving a girl how about you think about if it was you fine let's go save Glenn's damsel in distress oh la la oh my gosh being able to control the camera what's happening where am I oh my gosh oh that guy's licking the wall okay this is the plan you don't know how hard it's gonna be to get her out of that room you gotta get the female kill every one of them in here what not with the gun yeah quietly yeah yeah yeah okay with a knife over the wall oh man she's eating this oh so we got that one right there close okay all right that's kind of scary what is that a pillow and that is an rv okay and what's over here we've got a truck the girl's behind that door and the girl those two seem to be on the scent okay Pistol pillow.
It'll act as a suppressor.
Okay.
Um...
What?
Oh, so Glenn gets to peek for a long time, but not me.
I think the truck might be a better option.
Where to next?
I think the truck.
Let's go to the truck.
we can hide by that pickup yeah I think the truck shit happens oh my gosh okay oh my gosh let's examine we're gonna examine oh if I break it that's I need the pillow!
I think I found a pretty damn good way to stop these guys quietly.
We need the pillow!
We just have to get it quietly.
Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Okay, back, back, back.
Nice, okay.
So let's go...
Um, look at brick wall.
Oh, wait.
This guy is so chill.
Okay.
Nice.
She's cooking.
Now grab the pillow.
pillow.
Take.
Okay.
Good luck smothering them to death.
That's not really what I have in mind.
Yeah.
Smart ass.
Okay.
Run to the truck.
Battery girl.
You tell him.
I think I'm gonna have problems with that.
What are you gonna do with that?
I don't really know.
Do you have any tricks for getting into cars?
Not without tools or making a bunch of noise.
And none with pillows.
But if I... I guess though.
I use... Actually, wait a second.
When I thought of the pillow, I was thinking that it would shield my hand when I punched it.
But it would still make a lot of noise, huh?
Now that I think about it.
But I was like, oh yeah, it'll help my hand.
The door handle has a prompt?
Well dang.
Nice try though.
That one sitting down is just as dangerous as the others.
I know.
I know everybody is dangerous.
But now, now we do have a pillow.
Who is the guy kind of sitting down?
I want to look at him.
Wait, can I smother him?
Alright, Beth.
If it went for that fellow lurking near the front.
Oh, he's nasty.
I'm gonna smother him.
Get out your gun.
What the noise?
Just follow my lead.
Wait, is this gonna work?
I don't think this is gonna work.
That was sick.
What was that?
Just the wind.
Oh, dang!
Wait, the pillow really is a suppressor!
Look at that guy.
Wait, there's the...
Is that the axe you guys are talking about?
Huh, huh?
I prefer cover that can't just roll away.
What if we open the door?
What's the point?
Spark plug.
Okay.
I don't know what we'll need this for, but...
Because the pillow is a perfect silencer.
I'm suspending my belief.
See, I feel...
Wait, so...
Honestly!
Oh my gosh.
They really want to get into that room.
punching the window with with the pillow seems just as realistic as using the pillow as a suppressor honestly
um what will this do is this gonna make the car move because then we'll be exposed and I um
honestly I think your idea is better thank you I felt like I was cooking
Just do it?
The spark plug.
You should hold on there.
Good coming to hand you.
Yeah.
So now we push the car?
Where are we pushing?
Where are we dropping, boys?
Oh, we're gonna...
Oh my gosh.
Uh...
Okay.
It was awesome.
This sucks for that guy.
Okay.
A Leon would be helpful right now.
My goodness, you're so right.
Okay.
Well...
There's a pig in the head.
truck yeah but how do i get it now let's clear out the area around the rv oh by the rv let's get the ones over there head upstairs and get out of you okay let's go back there
was nothing else though no i think we could oh wait we could run to the rv we can hide by that rv if we're quiet and keep yeah he's got his back this he's looking that way so I think we could run over there and now this guy won't see us because he's pinned or rather he will but he can't get us so we might we might be able to get him I think let's try it's safe so if I die I die running running running running quiet quiet Quiet,
quiet.
Okay.
We're a little naked out here, except for Connie's gone and we can't use that much.
I know, I know.
Oh my gosh!
Okay, just kidding.
Um, let's go back home.
Running, running, running, running, running, running, running, running, running, running, running.
Let's uh, I didn't try to look at the car again, so let's do that.
Running, running, running, running, running, running, running, running.
thing now that I have the spark plug which I don't think it's gonna change anything but let's just see oh wait no way wait let me see the spark plug let me see the spark plug of course I'm inside these things turns car windows to tissue
Okay.
It wasn't...
That could scramble a brain pretty good.
It can.
It can, it can.
All right.
Back over here.
Must have been the win.
These guys have probably...
These zombies probably have an IQ of like 180 or something.
know all right get him
oh yeah oh yeah oh yeah
why would you do that
why did you do that wait aim for the head okay nice hey Oh, this is a big guy.
Oh, he's got no arm.
Dude, where'd your weapon go?
Oh, my gosh.
It's cool.
Now we've got this.
Are you two done?
Yeah, I think we should stop.
You know, I think this is two.
I think someone else should grab the ice pit.
I think someone else should grab it.
though oh my gosh i have to sneak up there oh golly okay why don't you guys lag behind just in case this goes to hell okay we'll be right behind you but now it's icky are the stairs gonna make a sound oh gosh okay it saved though so if i die
Okay, I'm not doing any of that.
He's walking all on his own.
Oh, my gosh.
I'm scared.
Get it.
I'm pressing.
Yay.
Okay, so you have to wait for the prompt as well.
Interesting.
You weren't clicking hard enough.
I didn't want it enough, clearly.
Hello?
Knock, knock.
Hello, and there.
We're here to help.
let's go guys was she cute Glenn is just like her voice was cute we've got a group in town she's in trouble miss we're coming in oh okay she's got a pretty voice why do we think who actually who put the the board on the door like that who did that you're hurt oh god i i said stay away oh we need to get you help it's too late for that oh guys she's been bitten what i told you i said go away i'm bit he's in love with her oh no let's calm down you could be fine i won't be fine my boyfriend was bitten you get sick and you die and and you come back and you kill anything you can find yeah yeah you have a boy friend no i don't want that it's not christian please just leave me please go no way um okay we'll leave okay we'll leave just try to take care of yourself whatever time you have you have a gun so can i borrow it what do you mean borrow give it to me i can just You know,
end this, and then there's no problem.
Whoa, whoa, whoa.
Please, I don't want to be one of them.
I don't know why they're fighting her.
Satanic.
Uh, give it to her.
Give it to her.
What?
You can't be serious.
You made a difficult choice.
Was it?
Um, look at her.
Yeah.
Look at her, Carly.
There's no happy ending to this.
Yeah.
Okay.
Fine.
just uh like do it quietly you know we'll get it back right thank you so much i know how terrible this must be we can't watch this let's go wait no we're gonna get it back right yeah what why not because somebody needs to pick up the gun exactly you two go on oh i stay okay you sure yeah Use the pillow,
ma'am!
God bless you, alright?
Aww.
God bless you, too.
Oh, right here?
I think she could have at least got inside.
Shut the door.
Oh, 7.
Dang.
Everyone alright?
Yeah, we had some close calls, but Glenn is fine and well, yeah, I don't think they were close at all Okay, I've got a few cans of gas in your pickup control Good to hear it and things back here Quiet our friend is still in and out over there.
He won't survive any more stress.
The next order of business is getting those pills out of the pharmacy.
Yep You were a machine I was basically a robot even to that lady like just just put her what's the point you know you gotta say you're wasting a bullet but that to me is is i would have had to use it anyway on a zombie i saved a future zombie suddenly she yells persona where's the door wait i'm lost clementine you okay
everything okay Mm-hmm.
Mm-hmm.
Oh.
Glenn, here I'm going to give you one.
I'm going to give you some of my food.
Don't tell the others.
I've found some snacks.
I'm cool.
Not much of an appetite.
Maybe save it for one of the kids.
How are you doing, Glenn?
Not your board, kidder.
Do you know the combination to the lock?
Do you know the combination for the lock on the gate outside?
Why?
Oh, you know.
I thought I'd go stretch my legs.
it if you have to oh no uh back at the motor end back to the motor end how can it be that bad so fast i know that's what i think people do crazy i guess that's not me i'm not giving up not for anything good man good you let her do it you know you said give her the gun i know i did why the hell would you do that?
Mercy.
Mercy, man.
I couldn't let her go on like that.
Yeah.
We couldn't.
You never know.
You can't give up hope.
I think it was over for, Glenn.
Uh-oh, they're mad at me.
I'm being realistic here.
I'm being realistic!
You have to be in this situation.
What a simp.
He's just mad that his future girlfriend is dead now.
What's your next move?
I don't know.
I mean, you guys seem okay.
What about your family?
Yeah.
I...
I... Forget it, man.
That's your business.
I hate feeling like I can't do anything.
I know the feeling, man.
Hey.
Try to get some rest.
Hey, Glenn.
Yeah, right.
Have you looked at Carly?
What about this girl here?
I don't remember her name.
quit being so dramatic oh wait can we do we use the axe now for the for the what's it called wait can I use the axe on here let's see if it works
oh okay there was an attempt
wimpy swing wimpy swing
Well, can I say I didn't try?
You guys okay?
Oh, we do.
If you don't mind, I think my family and I are going to rest for a bit.
Let me know if that asshole over there takes a turn for the worse.
You got it.
Do you guys want a snack?
I'm only sharing it with cool people.
It's not much but here.
For the boy.
Thanks, Lee.
He appreciates it.
Not sweet, Lee.
Don't share it with Ducky.
How are we doing?
Good.
Want to go have a look around outside?
Let's have a look around.
Okay.
Doug seems a little too eager to go look around outside.
You know what?
He seems a little like, hey, hey, you want to go look around outside?
to go look at the dead people i can't reach that brick oh no still do you think we're safe here well i haven't been able to get through this gate so far the drugs trust safe enough i think whoever owned it took good care of it it's well stocked and it locks up well he's a zombie enjoyer wait no i couldn't it would wait it would make the most noise ever let's try it
awesome now to distract those things carefully
i can't reach that brick um open it no just a tiny bit no that's way too much wait wait wait this is this doesn't feel Oh my god.
And...
Yee!
Go, Brew Force!
Yay!
Oh, no, not that...
One of those axes with the suppressor.
All right, Ikiimasu!
Okay, Doug, get out of the way.
get out of the way I'm going over there okay to my brother be careful keep an eye out will you how do we we're not safe in there anymore now though we don't have the lock anymore oh brother oh brother
I know if you were there, I would have died for you.
So yeah, I'm gonna assume that's what happened.
Okay.
Did you find them yet?
Give me a second.
Oh, well, yeah, no, I'm with Doug here.
Can we not yell also?
I have to finish you off now.
I got to do this now, man.
I got to do this.
I'm cold-blooded, I think.
Not even letting him have his peace.
Just realistic.
It's scary.
Oh my god.
Go for the head, man.
Go for the head.
Nothing.
There you go.
It keeps...
Yeah, he kept aiming for the neck for some reason.
Or was that mean?
Is it because I was clicking this?
Uh, was that me?
I thought that I had to click this.
Oh, well.
Yeah, I got an achievement.
I didn't read what it said, so...
Scripted aiming.
Holy crap!
Run!
Wait!
Um, I think that was you, Douglas.
Oh, we have nothing to...
Oh, my gosh.
Just keep...
it locked.
Maybe like a plank.
Man that was close.
But we did it.
It's all that meant.
Maybe like a plank on the door or something, you know.
Oh my gosh, Douglas, please.
Dougie.
Doug.
Great.
God, you're amazing.
Let's have one and more swings.
Oh yeah.
Please barricade the door.
Please, please, please, please, please.
That's the door to the pharmacy.
Yeah, yeah.
We should be able to find tools for Larry in there.
Oh, thank you for the redirect!
Hello, welcome, welcome.
Yeah, I had the key.
There you go.
I had it highlighted.
Okay.
There we go.
Oh, no.
Shit.
Oh, this is so...
Left for dead.
This is...
Oh.
Why is this...
Does the alarm automatically go off?
I opened it properly, no?
With the key!
Come
on, maybe time to go.
I'm gonna get the truck pulled up round back!
Do it fast!
I gotta get my dad out of here!
Oh my god, all she cares about is that...
There's more people here!
Get the hell out of the door behind me!
Glenn, when you hear me honking in the alley, start getting people out of here!
Wait, the cane!
Doug, Carly and Lee!
guys make sure our defenses stay up till then the cane i better take that axe in case i run into any of them on the way to my truck here you go all right that door's not locked anymore shit you three get on it i'll get back as fast as i can stay away from the windows oh wait wait wait wait okay oh my gosh what is happening what am i supposed to do oh my gosh we don't make it through this i should know that i think you're a great We'll make it through this.
We'll make it through this.
If we don't make it through this, you should know.
Oh my gosh.
Uh, uh.
I should know what?
Instead I should know that.
Oh my.
Are you sure?
What?
Oh my god!
Okay.
Can you look for something to stick in between the handles?
Something really wrong, okay?
Clementine, you know what to get You know what to get Nothing Oh
my gosh, oh my gosh Oh, his cane is gonna save his story.
No!
Oh, do we have to choose who to save?
Uh-oh.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Save Doug or Carly.
Oh, wait, who's who?
Oh, this is Doug.
This is Carly.
Um, I don't know who to save.
I think Doug would have wanted me to save Carly.
She also has really good AM.
Okay, it was like a death flag though.
When Doug said that we'll make it or that, you know, he was like, if we make it out of it, you know, it was...
You got Doug.
Get out of her neck
and then stab her.
Oh, I'm running, I'm running.
Not covered with this, you son of a bitch.
No!
No way!
Wait, what am I supposed to do here?
I'm not letting somebody else get eaten today.
Can't eat!
I'm especially a good friend.
Ah!
I should...
I...
We got that man's pills!
I think this is how he repays us?
You let Dennis die.
You don't even know his name.
Chugged.
Oh, my God.
Oh, man.
That was so awesome.
This is that ducky saying, Oh, Clementine, it was so awesome with the zombies.
No way.
It's a good thing we killed that girl, huh?
or else she would have been hiding in that room.
Yeah.
I've gotten the manless pills.
For real.
What a real loser.
Is that him screaming?
I hope so.
Oh no, that's her.
I'm gonna... I'm about to... I'm...
Hey, Glenn.
Oh.
Georgia's cities and their current level of disaster are as follows.
Atlanta, stage 9 catastrophe.
Augusta, stage 9 catastrophe.
Huh?
To Atlanta.
Yeah.
I got friends there.
And I just can't stay here knowing that they could be trapped in that city.
Did you just not hear that they said stage 9 catastrophe?
When we left a few days ago, could have gone either way.
I gotta take my chances.
Wait, Glenn, no!
Is it a girl?
He's going on TV.
So what is Glenn from the show?
He's got to go back to TV.
Glenn, no!
TV!
He has to...
He has to go off and then get got by Negan.
I think that's the wrong call.
Yeah, actually, if we keep him with us, Glenn, Glenn, you won't live.
I've seen the future.
Glenn, I've seen the future.
Don't go to Atlanta.
Glenn,
Glenn, the ratings are going to tank.
Glenn, the show will be ruined.
Nobody will watch it anymore.
Don't try to change the future.
Oh.
You won't live here either.
No, I believe in us.
You gotta do what you gotta do.
What was it?
What is a baby's gotta do what a baby's gotta do.
Come with us if you want to live.
You gotta do what you gotta do.
And I gotta do this.
I respect that.
You guys be safe.
We'll try.
And Lee, you know, if this doesn't get better, people are going to give up.
There's no spin-off for you.
If they go from upstairs.
Your actions have created a ton of power dogs.
You told Carly to give her the gun.
dude maybe you were right i don't know how to handle something like that he's still so but heard about that see you around see you on tv
blend oh that guy is over there oh that guy is over there
he's just yapping off poor clementine's ear
you say squidish Hold on.
Hey, Kim.
Close call back there.
Thanks for picking me up.
No problem.
We have to take care of each other.
Yeah.
We do.
Earlier, I mentioned you got to ask yourself what you're going to do if Clementine's parents don't show.
Yeah, you did.
You think that's going to happen?
Her parents showing up?
No, I don't.
Well, I want you to know that I think you've got it in you.
I think you can take care of that little girl just fine.
Oh!
Thanks, Kenny.
got it yeah we got her we got her
done this one time I'm forced over to I Carly how you doing Carly I'm okay you know considering I do I miss Doug I can't stop thinking about Doug me too I don't think so I know it's stupid We just met and he was such a it's just that I think that I liked him I'm sure he I'm sure he liked you too.
You better have anyway, I'd rather be alone.
I think you you insulted him Was she being too dead eh?
Wait, Lee What is it?
How did you choose?
We both needed you you picked me I was going to help you both.
I was going to help you both.
But you helped me first.
Oh.
Yeah, I did.
You're a sharpshooter.
I just wish we both could have made it, you know?
Me too, Carly.
I like that you have a small brain.
What are you tinkering with there, girl?
I don't think you...
Oh, she's going through supplies.
Oh, my God.
Let's go save Clementine finally.
This poor girl.
I got so...
super dinosaur was toast but you know what he wasn't oh and then hey duck uh you want to cool it for a minute okay sorry i'm sorry duck shut the hell up no it's not that it's i got grabbed again i was there and i saved you yeah i fell and my walkie talkie broke glenn had the other one no oh i'm sorry don't be me Thanks.
I know I need to be tough.
I'm just sad.
We're walking!
I know it doesn't make any sense.
But it's how I used to talk to my mom and dad.
And now they're gone.
It's gone.
Maybe we can find you another one.
Yeah.
I'll just keep this one, I guess.
We can fix it.
We can...
Come here for a second.
Ooh, I'm gonna...
Ooh.
Let me go deal with this.
I like how his text is real.
Oh, my God, no!
No, please!
We need to put duct tape over him.
You like my daughter?
uh yeah she's great yeah she's great well stay the fuck away from her or what or uh everyone will know that you lee everett are a killer and you were before it was something you had to do to stay alive i know who you are and i don't give a shit about what happens to you but if anything happens to my daughter or that little girl you've got with you you watch your ass you watch your ass hey my ass is nice do you have a second oh yeah in fact i do my dad would be dead if it weren't for you i wish your dad were dead god doug is dead because of me you can't be like that you're only one man i don't know music change we're lucky to have you oh my god that ducky is still yapping in the background I can't take...
I hope that's the sound of us winning this thing.
Me too.
This motor inn's pretty damn defendable.
We block off the entrances with some cars.
Keep someone on watch.
We could stay here until the military rolls through.
I actually agree with that plan.
Or if they blow through, as in blow up.
And most importantly, we got light.
There are worse places to call home.
Yeah, you're right.
Yeah, it's a good thing we took care of the lady in that room.
It's going to be okay.
oh why did they jinx it immediate fine if we survived the walkers never expected they'd starve us out oh poor Clementine I want you to have this okay in case you or Clementine starts feeling weak you don't know me anything Carly how you doing we got to get food Lee soon Heidi I'm Andrew st.
John we're from the st.
John dairy Wow I never did thank you for saving duck from the walkers back at Herschel's farm.
Something's coming, Lee.
Here's gonna be a war.
Uh-oh.
The walkers don't worry me as much as the bandits.
Oh!
You fucked with us!
Who?
Now we're gonna take what we want!
What?
Why is Otacon behind us?
Oh, yeah.
No more, please.
Lee, please.
Holy moly.
they just those are the worst kinds of trailers they tell you everything that's going on oh wow wait honestly lied to Herschel you and 63% of players were honest you and 49% of players chose to be duck
nobody wants to get duck you and 48% of players defended Kenny you and 45% of players gave her the gun.
You had 76% of players chose Carly!
No!
I missed Doug.
I should have chose... I should have picked Doug.
Oh, God.
God, I should have picked Doug.
Put in batteries correctly.
Poor Dennis oh my god I should have picked Doug who's Doug don't do my man like that
yay we did the first episode I'm having so much fun so far poor Doug yeah poor dog.
I missed tennis.
Uh, why?
Why, Doug?
Why not Larry?
Gosh.
But for the most part, I'm trying to be as like a quote unquote proper playthrough.
Trying not to cause too much chaos.
since this is my first time playing.
I do miss Doug.
I feel a lot of regret.
I'll do you one better.
Why is Minky?
I'm never gonna...
I'm never gonna go for the lady again.
Unless she's good.
I don't know.
Harley's fine.
She's just really stupid.
She's also kind of mean.
She thinks my ideas are bad.
She's not supportive at all.
Rip Danny.
Devin Dalton Jennifer.
Rip Dylan.
Miss Flupipaz.
And me!
Oh my gosh, I'm here.
War one out for Darren.
Carly's a good pick, though.
Ah.
Rip, Devin.
But I guess we'll call it here.
And we'll continue next week.
Yes, yes.
Continue next week.
Might actually do multiple of these episodes in a week.
Just so we can get... How many episodes is
Try Princess, thank you!
The proper playthrough.
Natural board.
Carly might not be the best asset on the team.
Not sure if she's above or below duck, though.
Duck?
Five?
Oh, okay.
Yeah, we'll see.
We'll see.
Five episodes per chapter.
Yeah.
All zombies this week for you, huh?
I'm all zombie.
I'm in my zombie era.
Thanks for the stream.
Your new outfit is very cute.
I'm so hyped for the cover.
Thank you.
Yes, I have a cover coming out, guys.
You should definitely watch it tomorrow when it premieres.
And I'm going to be doing some karaoke a little bit afterwards.
Logan, thanks for the vibe, get this.
Thank you.
And yeah, looking forward to it.
It's so... Gosh, the music video looks great.
I just love the song.
I'm super duper hyped for it.
I love Clem.
Basically the reason I have kids now?
Because of her?
I think Duck would have figured out the battery thing.
Duck.
Duck feels like a real boy.
Just yapping the poor Clem.
What a great birth week.
Dirty Laundry, happy birthday again!
Thanks for the stream.
Your new outfit looks so cute.
Thank you!
I'm glad you guys like it.
I'm very, I'm honestly so, I was very shocked by, like, how everybody reacted to it.
Like, I'm, you know, obviously I'm, I thought it was very cute, but I'm very happy that so many people think it's cute.
Yeah, so thank you, thank you.
very happy very happy but yeah I will see you guys when I see you next have a good day have a good night oh well I will put these on for my goodbyes and yeah thank you everybody for hanging out with me have a good day have a good night bye bye bye bye bye Wait,
what do I look like bald?